I not only have we let down the women in  this case the survivors who've  courageously come forward  I completely recognize that's going to  be the reaction of many women across  London indeed more widely  all I can say is I'm sorry I'm sorry  that we've let you down and you have my  absolute word we're going to be ruthless  about sorting this out about getting  these people out the way and creating an  organization that's better at dealing  with the plague of sexual violence that  we see in the country we have seen some  green lights over the last decade it's  good news that women's confidence has  grown and for example the reporting of  rape has tripled over the last decade so  that there has been progress made but  every time we get a case like this  particularly one as ghastly as this it  is going to shake that confidence I  recognize that and I'm determined to  confront it